so far so good
[Music]
hello anybody
they weren't kidding
[Music]
maybe i'll just have one little pig
how come you're not eating your snack i
prefer my snack to be a reward for
homework well done
you're like an old person thank you
[Music]
what's your homework non-euclidean
geometry how about you
synonyms you mean synonyms
i'm pretty sure she said synonyms
did you see that someone's out there
no they're in the backyard what do we do
[Music]
would one of you please get me a towel
why are you sneaking around out there
yeah you scared us
i was checking up on you two and in case
you're wondering you scared me back
well why didn't you knock because you
two are supposed to be doing this
on your own and you don't think we can
of course i do i'm the one who told your
mother that you were fine by yourselves
in the first place then why are you
checking up on us
that's called being two-faced we'll be
okay on our own
yeah we need to prove we can do this
all right i respect that
and i'm happy to keep this little
incident
a secret really i'm telling everyone it
was hilarious
[Music]
i'm going bowling
bye
[Music]
you